so can we've been talking a lot about
the early stages of the civil war which
were about slavery and the spread of
slavery and I think in popular culture
when we think about things like Abraham
Lincoln and the Civil War and slavery
the the term Emancipation Proclamation
or the idea of the Emancipation
Proclamation comes to mind and I think a
lot of folks imagine it to be this
really amazing speech that at some point
you know Lincoln makes his Proclamation
and after that point slavery is just
gone from the United States is is is
that what it was
no it's actually a lot more complicated
than that so the Emancipation
Proclamation itself was not a speech it
was actually closer to a decree
even though Lincoln didn't originally
come into his presidency intending to
end slavery it became pretty clear in
the first year of the war that he was
anti-slavery he didn't want to spread he
didn't think that he could end it right
so he specifically says in his inaugural
address that he has no intention of
ending slavery and that if the slave
states returned to the Union everything
will just go back to the status quo but
it very quickly becomes apparent in the
Civil War that ending slavery is going
to have to be a goal of the north for
one thing the slaves provide so much of
the production for the south that
interfering with that production is
really important for the north to secure
victory but it also is important on a
moral ground as almost as soon as the
war begins in slave men and women in the
south start going to Union lines hoping
for the army to protect them they want
to be part of the war effort they
interpret it as a war to end slavery
long before Abraham Lincoln interprets
it as a war to end slavery so it becomes
clear by the summer of 1862 that the
Union is going to have to deal with
slavery one way or another now once
again the reason why it's strategically
important is that this war is not going
as well as the north would have hoped or
as Lincoln would have hoped it's it's
it's it's lasting longer the first years
we mentioned
this video this the the South was
winning and it was going on the
offensive and then also on the moral
argument I guess it gave the north
something more to fight for yes and even
in some pockets of the South individual
Union generals were even making their
own small Emancipation Proclamation so
it became clear that the North was going
to need an overall stance on whether
this was a war to end slavery and
Lincoln decides yes this is going to be
a war to end slavery and so does he
announce it you know just all of a
sudden or is he kind of waiting for the
right time he's definitely waiting for
the right time in the summer of 1862 he
makes the first draft of the
Emancipation Proclamation and even in
the summer he shows it to the members of
his cabinets and they're shocked most of
them are themselves very strongly
abolitionist but they are terrified that
this document is going to be so
revolutionary at a time when the north
is already struggling that it's going to
force the border states out that many of
the whites in the north who don't care
about the fate of slaves are going to
leave the war effort so they advise
Lincoln not to just proclaim the
emancipation proclamation but rather to
wait for a big Union victory to kind of
put a stamp on the document and just to
make sure we understand I mean the fear
of his advisors was not all the Union
states were free states you had states
like Missouri and and Kentucky and and
Maryland that were that were slave
states but still part of the Union and
so the fears if you emancipate if you
say that if you make this Proclamation
all of a sudden those states would leave
right and those are very important
states they have a very large white
population
relative to their enslaved population
which means that if they go to the south
all of those fighters will go for the
south
and it's also where a lot of the South
this industry is so it would mean that a
tremendous amount of manpower and also
industrial power would join the south so
Lincoln and his cabinet are very
concerned about alienating these states
they want to make sure that their power
doesn't go with the south there's the
Emancipation Proclamation and slavery in
those states or the entire nations are
just in the salad or just in the
Confederate States so this is a strategy
of military necessity as Lincoln says he
specifically excepts the border states
from the Emancipation Proclamation steps
them he says they they this does not
apply to them so it's not a pure moral
ground that slavery is evil and needs to
be gone from the earth he's saying in
these states that are trying to secede
he is banning slavery right and he
almost makes it like a form of
enticement for the south to come back he
says here is my plan for emancipation I
am going to put it into effect on the
first day of January 1863 he puts it out
in September of 1862 just after the
Union victory at Antietam so this is
this big Union victory gives him the the
backdrop the context the context and in
which he can put the Emancipation
Proclamation out there but he says if
the states that are in rebellion come
back into the Union before January 1st
then it will be Nolan void I see so he's
still trying to get him back in the fold
and he's willing to accept slavery at
least for the time being if he could end
this war that's turning out far bloodier
and far longer-lasting than frankly
anyone especially folks in the North had
expect it to be so he didn't immediately
say hey no more slavery we're trying to
make the South fight even harder it's
like hey well you know I'm gonna make
this effective in January January 1863
which would be over here so you have a
couple of months to come back come back
to the mothership so just be right
and the South does not take him up on
this offer so when January 1st 1863
rolls around he signs the Emancipation
Proclamation and we have some of the
text of the proclamation here and what I
think is interesting and we have this
right on the Kahn Academy site on and
one of the articles is that it you know
it doesn't have the beauty of the
Declaration of Independence or even the
Constitution it actually reads kind of
like a legal document I mean if I read
this that on the first day of January in
the year of our Lord 1863 all persons
held as slaves within any state or
designated part of a state so it's kind
of this legalese the people aware of
shall then be in rebellion against the
United States shall be then
thenceforward and forever free and the
executive government of the United
States including the military and naval
authority thereof will recognize and
maintain the freedom of such persons and
will do no act or acts to repress such
persons or any of them in efforts in any
efforts they make for their actual
freedom which is a really nice thing to
say but it reads like a like a legal
document I could I could keep keep going
I encourage the folks listening to to
read and it literally lists the various
states and as you mentioned it's much
more of a decree it's not this beautiful
speech right and we know Lincoln for his
beautiful speeches the Gettysburg
Address is perhaps the most famous
speech in American history and so it's a
little bit strange that arguably the
most important thing that Lincoln ever
does is arguably the ugliest piece of
writing that Lincoln ever put out there
it's because he's a lawyer and we forget
sometimes about Lincoln's background as
a lawyer but he practiced for decades
and so what he's trying to do here is
really create an ironclad legal document
that no one can turn around later and
say well here's a loophole yeah although
that has its moments I mean right here
and upon this act and upon this act
sincerely believed to be an act of
Justice warranted by the Constitution
upon military necessity I invoke the
considerate judgment of mankind
and the gracious favor of Almighty God I
mean it's kind of it's still kind of a
legal yeah it's it's yeah it's not
moving to the passions or to the moral
as much as kind of and he off even also
talks about well it is what it is well
that will let other people judge it for
it on their own but you know what's
really important about the Emancipation
Proclamation is from that point forward
even though he's particularly putting
this on the southern states where any
jurisdiction he has is really just what
can be enforced by the army
it turns the Union Army into an army of
liberation that as they go throughout
the South enslaved people will flock to
them and want to contribute to the war
effort and shortly after this Lincoln
will make it possible will put one part
of the Emancipation Proclamation is
saying that African Americans can join
the Union Army as soldiers and so they
really from this point forward can play
an active role direct and recognized
role in ending slavery and this is
really the moment when slavery truly
starts to crumble